we did three worked examples before and
we're gonna go pressing a little further
into the exercise now you'll notice I
skipped a bunch of questions when I
assign those questions earlier in the
exercise 1e and that's because I wanted
to cover with you what we're about to do
now so have a look at this particular
diagram find the shaded area you've been
told that this is the function y equals
x squared and then the sketch is
provided so I'm being gracious and
merciful and providing you the sketch
you don't need to redraw this okay but I
mean unfortunately you don't have the
drawing yourself so if you want to do a
rough version of this you'd have to
think about it too hard but you do need
to be able to see this in front of you
okay now how do you find this shaded
area there's two ways to approach this
I'm going to show you both of them but
first let's have a think about how would
you tackle this and why is it different
to the questions we were looking at
earlier now you might remember when we
first introduced this we talked about
areas under curves this is not an area
under a curve it's an area above a curve
now we've seen that you can do a bare
areas above curves if they are beneath
the axis but this one is not this one in
its entirety is above the axis so what
do we do with this thing okay now like I
said there's two ways to go about it
what can we do using the knowledge that
we already possess well because the
knowledge we already possesses to do
with areas under curves if I were to
integrate this particular y equals x
squared in between the relevant
boundaries I would get an area beneath
this orange spot here so the first
question I ask is what are the
boundaries right what are the
appropriate boundaries here where do I
want to start and where do I want to end
I'm looking for X values here right here
and here can you tell me what those are
key is my screen good enough resolution
for you guys to read off can you tell me
what the boundaries should be nice one
mowie gets in first fantastic not that
speed is the thing that's most important
but I am still impressed nonetheless so
I'm going from zero to four and
admittedly I mean the diagram tells you
it's zero anyway so if I integrated I'm
just going to write this at the top here
if I integrated from zero to four and
took this function
x squared right what area would that
give us it would give us an area I just
wouldn't give us this particular orange
one okay I'll show you the area we would
get it would be underneath the curve
bounded between 0 & 4 so it would be
this guy right now this area here is not
the one I'm after but it is closely
related to the one that I'm after can
you see what how I could take this blue
area this one that I'm shading and
cross-hatching it now how I could take
this guy and use it to work out the
orange one do you want to make any
suggestions in the chat what could I do
with this
yeah good you're on the you're on the
right track yeah there we go perfect
yeah you're good Corrections for
yourself there Jason
so there's a there's a big rectangle
that goes all the way around this right
let me draw it in a big bold color so
here in red all the way on the left and
right top and well there's the bottom
bottom in top okay so this red right
rectangle here right if I work out what
that is and then subtract the blue area
exactly right Trisha I will get the
orange area that I'm after so in other
words the area would be equal to well
what is that by the way the red
rectangle what are its dimensions we
already know its width right goes from 0
to 4 so it's with this 14 can you read
off of my graph of my axes can you use
the scale what's the height going to be
yeah nicely done Abby so 16 from naught
to 60 in there right so when I'm working
out my area here I'm gonna say area
equals 16 times 4 that's the rectangle
and then I'm going to subtract this
integral and that will give me the
answer let's just give this a go and see
how we turn out this is going to be 64
takeaway and we can do this integral
this is the part that we're quite good
at right this is going to be X cubed on
three integrals increase indices from
naught to 4 just watch out for that
minus sign at the front 64 takeaway
let's start evaluating now 4 cubed
happens to also be 64 over 3 and then
you take away zero okay so
before takeaway 64 over three you might
be able to put that in your calculator
I'm pretty sure it'll be 128 over three
so therefore the area is 128 over three
units squared okay so this is a way that
we can evaluate this area it's kind of
indirect we worked out the area by
working out what the area isn't and then
doing a bit of subtraction but it works
fine and it uses all of the knowledge
that we've already developed okay so I'm
going to call this guy method 1 this is
I guess you could call it by subtraction
so we worked out the area under the
curve which we are very good at doing
but we worked out that that area isn't
the one we want we need to subtract that
from this rectangle